I'm an idiot now
[laughter] I couldn't see
anything I wasn't trying to see
this girl She's
neither an angel nor a goddess She's a
lonely girl I'm sorry What I said was a
lie That's right
Yo,
Gundo-san is trying to make you feel depressed
Carol-
chan
[music] is
for me Why is it
for Kou-chan when Misuzu-chan
bullies me?  Thank you
Carol for showing me so much It seems there's no escape from yawning
anymore
Ms. Kondo
gave me a push so I can tell you
how I feel I
love you
Carol I'm sorry I'm
late
[music]
You know, you know, I love Kou-chan too
Thank you, I'm
so happy Why did Carol fall in love with me
? I've never thought about it.
Because you've been kind to me so much I
don't know when or why I
love you because I love you
[Music]
Wait, what's that